the agenda is set i'm brent goff in
berlin it's time to talk
they fight chemical weapons and they've
won the nobel peace prize but why isn't
the world cheering
some say this man is worthy of a nobel
prize is it really time to rethink
putin's russia
and attempted coups and militias galore
libya welcome to north africa's wild
west
welcome to the show everyone i've
invited three people today to talk argue
and pry apart
these headlines my first guest today
says libya is close to anarchy he has
dodged bombs himself in libya in fact he
did that when gaddafi was overthrown
happy to welcome to the show the
journalist and former member of the
german parliament mr jurgen turden
herfer mr nurse good to have you on the
show today you are an outspoken critic
of the west's policies in libya look
forward to hearing from you today on the
show
my second guest says that russia
is changing and the world had better
take notice i'm happy to welcome to the
show dmitry trenton he is director of
the carnegie moscow center he's here
today to tell us why europe and the us
need to accept that russia is no longer
a geopolitical spoiler demetri good to
have you on the show as well and my next
guest was thrilled when she heard that
the nobel peace prize had been awarded
to the organization for the prohibition
of chemical weapons she helped to set up
the opcw back in the 1909 i'm happy to
welcome to the show
mitzla keflecius to the show thank you
it's love it's good to have you on the
show let me begin with you by asking you
does the chemical weapons watchdog
deserve the nobel peace prize yes
greatly because i think in today's
international politics it's necessary to
recognize who are the actors who can
participate in this building and one of
the international organization which was
built to destroy the chemical weapons
which is the organization for the
prohibition
of weapons chemical weapons is one which
got the nobel prize and i consider noble
doesn't mean
only for individuals who have done a
nobel prize
noble activities but individuals in a
collective who have achieved that
deserves also to be saved
what they have done is noble okay i mean
the nobel committee you know agrees with
you gentlemen what do you think i mean
does this watch dog deserve the nobel
peace prize dimitri
well i say this
whether it deserves or not is uh
is not a subject in which i would like
to weigh in i think it's more
interesting to see a new trend emerging
within the nobel
peace prize committee they are not
giving
the prize sometimes
for achievements for accomplishments
rather they think ahead they gave the
nobel peace prize to obama president
obama
uh not for any accomplishments by that
time but for the trend that he
represents like an advanced check right
and this is the same thing on on the eve
of the operation
unprecedentedly difficult operation in
syria to give a peace prize to the
organization that will be engaged in
this potentially deadly activity i think
that was behind the thinking of the
people
do you agree jurgen no
i would
think about this idea to give a peace
novel peace prize to these people
if they would persuade the united states
to destroy their chemical weapons they
have still have a lot
and they say they need till 2020
to destroy them so this would be this
would need so you're saying it was so
you're saying it was not the right
decision to give this watchdog of course
for that all right well you know there
there was a collective disappointment
last friday in much of the world when
the news came that the 2013 nobel peace
prize is going to the world's chemical
weapons watchdog the opcw
most bets were on the 16 year old
pakistani girl known simply as malala
who was shot by the taliban for daring
to go to school malala has become an
international symbol of hope in the face
of violence hatred and war she inspires
people to do better
few people knew about the opcw until it
became part of the plan to somehow
defuse the syrian civil war on paper the
watchdog looks like a force for good but
on the ground many say that the opcw is
powerless to promote real peace
this year's nobel peace prize was
awarded to the opcw for its efforts in
eliminating chemical weapons
experts from the hague-based
organization have carried out over 5 000
inspections since 1997 in dozens of
countries
60 000 tons of chemical weapons have
been destroyed as a result
the opcw has been in the spotlight
recently for its deployment to syria
it's been charged with destroying the
country's entire chemical weapons
stockpile by
mid-2014 that is a dangerous mission
taking place in the midst of a civil war
that's killed over a hundred thousand
people in two years
the nobel committee said recent events
in syria where chemical weapons have
been used show how crucial it is to do
away with them
but destroying chemical weapons is only
part of the effort to achieve peace so
how effective can the opcw be
that that is the big question now is
this watchdog going to promote peace in
syria
that's what the world wants to know yeah
let me say first that i i cannot talk on
the behalf of the organization because
i'm not representing the organization
but my own personal opinion
yes it does
there are many aspects one
one has to remember is chemical weapons
are a mass destruction weapons this is a
weapon which can destroy in a very
limited time an enormous of people
an enormous of places as a result to
destroy them and to have an
international organization which
verifies inspectors the destruction of
chemical weapons is a very important
activity is that is that happening
though it does happen i mean we i don't
have access to the documentation or to
the declarations itself but the
destruction of a chemical weapon is a
very long approach creating a chemical
weapon is the very easy but destroying
it takes a lot of time my question is
how can we verify that what is being
disclosed to the opcw is true how do we
know that bashar al-assad is telling the
truth about his chemical weapons
stockpile
well there are many aspects for
individuals or for member states an
international organization like opcw is
a member states organization it's not an
individual so member states have a right
to ask and have a right to verify
whether the information which are
collected by the organization are
correct and that's why we have to ask
yeah well not only they ask there is a
lot of instruments of inspection there
is a trial inspection there is on-site
inspection there is a challenge
inspection
there's never been a challenge
inspection since this watchdog started
right well
even if there would have not been a
challenge inspection only places where
the threat of chemical weapons would
happen is in the case of syria so syria
was not the member of the opcw as a
result you cannot also have a
challenging expectation to syria itself
but between among member states member
states they commit themselves to fulfill
an international treaties and to give an
institution i agree with you and i i
think probably a lot of people in the
international community are going to ask
um how can we believe bashar al-assad
when he commits to anything now at this
stage and that's why the the validity of
what the watchdog is telling us now
a lot of people are going to
have a problem believing that
gentlemen i mean i i was a spokesman for
arms control during seven years during
the time of nuclear arms deployment in
germany
of course you can hide chemical weapons
and if assad would like to hide chemical
weapons he could but he would be
completely crazy he has a political
reason
to open everything up because
these talks about chemical weapons
open the possibility to have talks about
a peace solution in syria
that's the importance
of these inspectors
because beside the talks about these
chemical weapons the americans have
without
faith
losing their face they have the
possibility to talk
to assad
and to open the channel and to try to
find out if there is a way to solve this
horrible tragedy
with negotiations well i mean i'm not
worried about the americans losing face
here i'm
my concern is can this agency
get
accurate and truthful information
from the member states well it does
not no no there is a way you can get it
because the question is in in the
chemical weapons the impact of chemical
weapons is whether you have one gram or
not gram is not the implication among
member states among state relationship
whether it is correct is this the
process peace is builded in the process
peace is not built because you gave me
an information today it means tomorrow
you can also build it i mean chemical
weapons to build a chemical weapon is
not a big
technology the fact is that estate when
a state commits itself or willing to
commit to itself and opens the door for
verification for inspection it is a big
achievement
because peace building is not made only
because you have made a declaration i
say this i think that um
the crucial issue here is that asset is
interested
in playing by the rules
he has received a lot in return for his
willingness to disarm chemically
his
he would be in a very bad situation he
knows if he is caught cheated cheating
so he is he is not crazy he is a
rational thinking person
and he has every reason to stick to his
commitment that's a better guarantee
than anything you can have from the
organization from the international
community or from anyone else and i
think that the russians have told him in
in no uncertain terms
that they will be backing him as long as
he sticks to that commitment mr putin
has invested too much in that and he
doesn't want to be second guessed by
bashar al-assad there's another
guarantee the russians have constructed
the stores where the chemical weapons
are
and they are watching them so they have
much more control that the world public
knows
it's a it's it i i really don't know how
much actual influence the russians have
there
uh it's it's it's always been a pretty
close state uh but i think i think the
political
uh issue here is more is even more
important but the russians have i think
a lot of intelligence i mean you know i
look at the case um we're going to talk
about libya later on in the show but
just talk about when libya joined
um the opcw i think it was um what 2004.
and gaddafi
disclosed what he had
and we found out of course later that he
did not tell the truth that he had these
stockpiles hidden
that we found out of course after he was
toppled and
why
are why should we assume that bashar
al-assad would not do something similar
to that
well let's take the consideration the
scenario even he has something to hide
okay one is the chemical weapons having
chemical weapons even for the military
itself it's not a safe instrument but
let's say you take a state a
head of state is lying and not telling
the truth but despite that the the role
of an international organization a role
of a neutral possible natural ground
where member states could participate is
you start a process within the process
you have a state which is sitting in
front of you to ask declarations to
verify the declaration whether it's the
truth maybe the destruction of the
chemical weapons would not happen like
the way we wish it within one or two
years which will take time but you have
started the process i mean a negotiation
and this is peace purity i i just wonder
how successful the organization is going
to be i mean we want to talk about you
know
getting the nobel peace prize when i
look at the numbers the united states
has not destroyed all of its
stockholders
90. 10 still exist
um russia um has destroyed about 76 is
the latest number i found um
you have all of these countries that i
have
a lot of transparency
but israel is not a member of the op
chemical weapons but the point but the
point is you've got all this
transparency and yet no one is playing
completely by the rules so but sorry you
know you are just answering yourself the
united states has destroyed 90 percent
you know the cost of destruction of
chemical weapons a huge budget itself
the process not only the budget itself
the procedure of destruction takes time
but 90 percent of a destruction is
already a good achievement but more than
that the willingness for a member states
to to destroy is 100 percent is also an
achievement and also if you get whether
u.s or russia or any other member state
to allow an inspection that allow a
declaration to allow every year a
pressure to say you have not finished
the destruction that's a big power and
one should not underestimate it the fact
that we're so that we're having this
discussion is the nobel peace prize
diminished
by the fact that we can't really
pinpoint
achievement
well i think
i think it's it's a good argument i
think that
since you have to give the prize every
year on an annual basis
whether something happens or not you
you're obligated you cannot say there
have been no achievements in the world
worth being recognized with the noble
peace prize you're under pressure to
name somebody there's competition there
are people with all sorts of agendas
weighing in on the decision
on the decision making process so i
think yeah i mean it is uh it is
sometimes it's it's it's you you you
recognize the price as being as really
hitting the bullseye and sometimes it's
just you know placeholder you give it to
somebody for something that looks like
um you know in principle a good uh a
good thing or you try to but you try to
motivate with the price that that's the
new policy i think of this okay so it's
not rewarding it's motivating yeah yeah
that's where we are but also don't you
think you're looking at the world as if
it is a black and white and things has
to be precisely at this point one should
recognize processes but specifically in
today's politics
i agree i agree with you 100 on that but
i think when there are other candidates
um
for the prize who have clearly
demonstrated something amazing
extraordinary and they don't get the
price then obviously the discussion
begins what's the thinking going on
behind
this decision i mean it's a legitimate
question
let me ask you this because we have to
move on let me ask all three of you yes
or no do you think a year from now
will
the
opcw will it have earned
the peace prize
it's got a year to go into syria
and dismantle these chemical weapons
will it earn that prize in the next 12
to 14 months
what do you think
i would i think the price was given to
the wrong organization i think
the chance for peace
comes because we have now talks about
chemical weapons though they are just a
medium to have peace talks all right
they are the implementors
they are not those who made the process
possible
but they are the implementers they will
have to go into a civil war environment
and do their job lavrov did much more
what do you say yes they do because i
think
the member states are the one who gets
the ownership of the opcw's nobel prize
opcw is made by the member state and the
member states are achieving and if we
get it within the one year the whole
total uh
can collapse three plays
there is now better than that you could
wish and i believe the role of the media
the lord of this prize would give like
angola like south sudan like egypt like
syria has just joined we have only some
countries left and it would be very good
and i think it has
honored it already and
they would do it very good you know
several weeks ago i asked on this show
is russian president vladimir putin now
a contender for the nobel peace prize
and guess what he was nominated russian
media say that the nobel committee gave
a nod to putin by awarding the peace
prize to the opcw after all it was putin
who ran with the idea of putting serious
chemical weapons under international
control the biggest takeaway from all of
this is that the whole world is now
talking about russia as a game changer
in geopolitics no longer the spoiler but
suddenly the mover and shaker and some
faces here in the west are not reacting
with smiles
at the g8 summit in june relations
between barack obama and vladimir putin
were frosty the two leaders were backing
opposite sides in the syrian conflict
and peace seemed a long way off
but then russia pushed forward a plan to
destroy syria's chemical weapons
it had the double effect of removing the
need for a u.s military intervention and
protecting president assad
putin has always believed russia should
be taken seriously on the diplomatic
stage
now he was seen by some as making peace
where america could not
robot
but within his own country there is
conflict putin has shown a less dovish
streak in the war in cheshnia
and the crackdown on gay rights
demonstrators has raised concerns
especially in the west
as have the arrests of migrants
following anti-migrant riots in moscow
so what's the right balance between
criticism of putin's russia and
engagement with it
dmitry i want your opinion on this do
you think the nobel peace prize
committee was giving a nod
to putin no i don't think so
would be
i think would be too dangerous to be
seen as a friend of mr putin's in the
west i don't think so but a lot of
people are interpreting that
well people in russia may be
interpreting it like that but
well first of all we have not
seen the end of the story we're at the
beginning
right
the syrian chemical weapons are where
they are
the syrian civil war is raging around it
the whole thing has not been done the
whole thing is only at the at the very
beginning of being
done
so it's it's too early but the whole
world now is talking about russia
russia being
a game changer
russia is stealing the thunder from
washington
in in syria are are we looking at
a new
type of of russian power on the global
stage i don't think so i believe we
we're all overselling russia at this
point
i believe what happened was that
yes putin saw an opportunity out there
an opportunity to
prevent u.s military strikes against
syria
which he thought would spoil
the right trend
initiated by president obama
of retrenchment back to the u.s
he thought that that would mix it and
that would send us back to the bad days
now his longer-term goal
is to
i think
is to enhance the
influence of call them new isolationists
in the united states people who do not
believe in the value of military
interventionism around the world
from putin's perspective that would make
the world a better place a safer place
and that would give a bit more breathing
space to russia well it's about giving
him breathing space right because he
does he doesn't want the world looking
inside russia
and examining what's going on there well
the world is welcome to look inside
the world is not welcome to work inside
russia in putin's view to change things
in russia
so that's the difference i think we live
in in a world with glass borders
we very well see what's happening in
your neighbor's room or even in in some
room thousands of miles away from where
you are
that's that's no problem criticizing
people the problem i think from putin's
perspective and i'm not his fan
is to make sure that
no one
materially interferes in your country's
domestic politics
that's the issue and that's
international law
you don't have the right to interfere uh
that's that that's the argument that uh
mr putin is using absolutely yes and
that's what traditional law says i mean
but the paradox that a lot of people
talk about now is putin doesn't want to
recognize international law but at the
same time he wants to strengthen the
security council and he wants to he
wants to use the u.n as a bulwark
against the united states for any type
of intervention in another country it's
like he wants to have his cake and eat
it too
i would say that i don't think that he
is
he is a strong supporter of traditional
international law traditional
international law it's not so much the
the new additions which have not yet
become international law like
humanitarian interventionism he is very
much against that
but i don't think his goal is uh to work
against the united states i think he
wants
and
forgive me the expression to cut the us
down to size he wants the u.s to be a
primus enterprise
and not the hegemon that rules the world
that's putin's uh
help us read me to help us read russia
here is is this about
cutting america down to size or is this
about building russia up those are two
different things not he is building
russia up uh
primarily within russia he understands
pretty well how
how many problems russia has at this
point how brittle this notional
stability in russia is how dire the
economic situation in russia is what it
means to the social peace in russia a
couple years down the road what it means
to the political stability in russia we
were witnessing riots anti-immigrant
riots in in moscow
and that points to
in my view the greatest national
security threat to russia into ethnic
relations in bigger cities in russia so
mr putin is uh is is pretty much aware
of these and that's not on the radar of
the international community right now
well i mean that's something you know it
made headlines this past week the the
riots we saw in moscow but um i don't
think when the world looks at russia
they're looking at a nation that could
fall apart no it's not falling apart but
it's it's a nation beset well first of
all it's it's a country not a nation
right and that's that's
mr putin's big worry big concern big
plan is to build a nation he's building
it top down he's trying to build a
nation but haven't we been there before
dimitri i mean
didn't lenin tried to do that didn't
stand but we've been there before
lenin had
a communist project
and he um
he butchered
so many russians and stalin but i think
to construct that communist project but
why not run into the arms of your
western friends and neighbors they all
if you the people in europe and in the
united states they're mystified they
don't understand russia because they
think
the russians are just like
the west they think russia is the west
that's the old question
russia is european
but what the west means today is
is a um not a very clear concept we we
knew what the west was in the days of
the cold war uh today's west is is is
much
the borderline the borders of today's
west are much more blurred but let me
say this i think that the russians have
tried that before mr yeltsin tried to
become a formal ally of the united
states when it came to president bush
uniting the elder president bush in 1992
he said how about signing an alliance
with with us now
and bush basically said you know the
cold war is over we don't need alliances
we need partnerships
fine
uh that sounds good does it yeah right
right and then there was the enlargement
of nato that stopped at the russian
border it would have been a different
enlargement had it occluded russia and
there were people in russia who wanted
to be and yeltsin himself wanted to be
admitted to nato no russia was not seen
as eligible for that
mr putin himself and 19 in 2001
essentially pledged an alliance to the
the younger president bush
right after 9 11. and he he talked about
russia's european choice
now the u.s
administration lost interest in russia
the following year 2002 they moved on to
do iraq
russia was laying by the wayside
mr medvedev
on mr putin's
orders i should say in 2010
proposed
to nato what
looks like
to me
the equivalent of a strategic alliance
by merging ballistic missile defenses
right the west told him that it's still
early for that so is the is the west
does the west carry the blame then for
this
i'm not engaged in the blame game i
think that may may be the right thing
that russia was turned down every time
because
there's one thing about russia that does
not fit very well into the western
concept the west has a leader
a very well recognized leader
russia the russian elites are not ready
to accept anyone as their leader what's
putin no no any other country
as their leader okay i mean
that's the that's the problem could it
be also that the facts now what you're
saying also is demonstrating that putin
is believing more and international
treaties than an international
organizations to promote a national
interest rather than
this bilateral relationship and i i
think the case of specifically now syria
domestic putin bringing to the surprise
of the western let's call it the western
society saying okay let's give let's
open syria but not as an individual
america going uh doing a job but in the
international community and i would
participate in my own role of
influencing and this could be because of
the fact of the past experiences and
also the desire the only way you can
guarantee your sovereign right if you
believe in international organizations
which allows you to demonstrate that you
are sovereign
is also a necessity could that be also
the way that from putin's
role of international relationship i i
want to
mention we have to we have to move on so
i just wanted to pull up some numbers
here um about what the russians think
about the west
you know there's been some new numbers
that have come out and
the number of or the percentage of
russians who have a an unfavorable
opinion of the united states has
increased dramatically in the last 10
years but also
the percentage of russians who have an
unfavorable opinion of
the eu and europe has also increased
dramatically
um
what have we done yeah but there are a
lot of reasons when after the fall of
the soviet union
i think gorbachev has been very generous
he gave
the
he allowed the unification of germany
and they did a lot
and then we enlarged nato
till the borders of this country of
russia
and they have the feeling
that we didn't give back anything what
would a solution because we have to
would a solution be something very
radical to change policy with nato and
to invite
russia to become a full-fledged member
for the european union to also say we
want russia to become a full-fledged
member of the eu would that solve all of
this misunderstanding this was a chance
but i think we have missed the chance
and they don't trust
the western countries anymore and as far
as timity
was talking about the
targets of the russians i think they
have also a target they want to play a
role in the middle east
and they don't want to lose tattoos and
all
the middle east is extremely important
for the united states and therefore also
therefore it's important for the
russians
they want to play a role in the world
yeah all kinds but let me say just one
thing
yes because i think russia has now
stepped up to a totally new level of its
international engagement
and it clearly requires uh
more resources to play at that level
in resources of all kind
and i think it would be extremely
important now for russia to rise up
to that challenge that mr putin actually
has
has uh has accepted and uh we will see
it's it's
where we're only at the beginning
hopefully russia
can play at that higher level of
internet so you're bullish on putin's
russia uh no i'm not bullish i'm bullish
on russia let's go that way all right
all right we're going to move on did you
ever think that we would look
at libya
and long for the relative order that
muammar gaddafi gear indeed when he was
a dictator well a lot of people in libya
and around the globe are doing just that
the country
is a mess two years after the revolution
turf wars and clashes between rival
militia rule the day human smugglers
have turned libya into the main port of
departure for african migrants trying to
reach europe tripoli's zoo
is now a detention center for illegal
immigrants and as we saw last week it
takes just a handful of security guards
to send the government into chaos
prime minister ali zaidan was seized
from his bed in the early morning hours
he was abducted by more than 100 men
believed to be former members of rebel
groups that helped overthrow colonel
muammar gaddafi
said on was released hours later and the
exact circumstances of the kidnapping
remain unclear but the prime minister
has blamed armed militias and described
the incident as an attempted coup
there are about 200 000 armed militiamen
in libya
they're mostly paid by the government
but often they're loyal only to their
own commanders
in the days of colonel gaddafi such
lawlessness was unknown
but nato intervention not only helped
rebels topple the dictator it also left
a country with weak political
institutions
so is libya going from bad to worse
yeah jurgen you've been there you were
there also during the revolution
several times um is
libya
going to become a failed state
there is a huge danger that it is
becoming a failed state but
that's a little bit normal after a
revolution's countries need a lot of
time to begin
to have a stable
infrastructure to have a stable
government
france needed 80 years after the french
revolution to become a stable democracy
germany needed if you take also the time
of hitler
32 years
to become a democracy
and or to become a democracy again
and so they need time that's normal but
i think that the military intervention
of nato
has worsened
the things has made things more
difficult because
it destroyed
all the political structures
gaddafi still be in power had there been
no nato intervention no
you know first of all i think that
countries have to make their revolutions
themselves second i think
nato didn't interfere to bring freedom
to libya
they they never interfere we never
interfered in in iraq or in afghanistan
to bring freedom and human rights to
these people we interviewed because we
have interest
we have interests in this country
and nobody the international community
um i mean this was an international
effort i mean it wasn't one country
going and going along but the russians
for example they feel that they feel
cheated
because they accepted this intervention
but they didn't accept
a regime change
and at the end it became an effort to
make a regime change
and there was i was there
i was attacked by the troops of gaddafi
a friend of mine was killed i was
bombarded by the troops of gaddafi they
tried to kill me so i have no reason to
have sympathies for these men
but when the word public said now
gaddafi is advancing against benghazi
and he will commit
a massacre i was there two days before
i said why should he make a massacre
there was no he would never he wouldn't
have committed the message because a
massacre meant
that he would have lost everything in
this country so we like always before an
intervention we invented something but
we said he's we who is we the whole this
was the world opinion the media the the
politicians people who have never been
in a revolution people who have never
been in libya so you're saying you're
saying all of them that all the people
all the libyans who rose up against
gaddafi you're saying all of that was
fabricated by westerners no no
i said
that there was the hope to make
a revolution and to get democracy i was
with the rebels i was with young
students who wanted democracy but that's
another thing
but
this doesn't mean that we need a
military intervention by former
colonialists the french
colonialists the british colonialists in
this region and the
the italians too and they didn't come to
liberate this country they destroyed the
country they killed also many civilians
i was in many hospitals
i met people who lost members by this
intervention and this intervention
didn't help anything like all the
military interventions you you and
therefore i'm also with the traditional
international law
which
says
interventions in the
in other countries are not allowed
you just wrote a book in german uh the
english title of it is thou shall not
kill yeah
um
i've seen only misery by these
interventions in iraq what is in iraq we
went there to bring democracy where's
the democracy in iraq where where is
in afghanistan where is your anger
though okay
let's look at
what's happening let's compare syria and
libya yeah all right let's there's no
foreign intervention right now there's
no military campaign but the russians
continue selling weapons to syria and
those weapons are being used against
syrian citizens
is easy but saudi arabia is
where is your anger though at that
that business transaction going on that
also allows people to be killed yeah
first of all
i have been in libya
three four times during the revolution
and i've been in syria during this
revolution of this war
six times
and i think it's a tragedy
the security forces of the government
are killing people in a brutal way and
the rebels are killing people in a
brutal way and they both
like in the civil war in the united
states they both are killing killing
killing and what i say the solution
the solution is not a military
intervention the solution are
negotiations to start
would libya be better off if qaddafi
were still in power i don't say that he
should still be in power but he was
old and his time was running out and it
was up to the libyans to find a solution
and
but it was not up to the europeans
especially to france
united states is the libyan mess
um you know do we carry the west is it
our fault not only
i don't think it's our fault but it
didn't improve anything it killed people
and now the country is destroyed it's
destroyed by the revolution but it's
also destroyed by this intervention and
let me let me say one more thing we're
running out of time do we just do
anything
just one thing i would say this you go
in
you break it you own it
right you have to stay and see it
through it's an ex it's an extremely
difficult decision to go in but once
you're in
you're in for the long haul you've got
to fix it you cannot walk away 10 years
later and then is that is that the
russians the russians went into chechnya
right
grozny was leveled
chechnya is of course part of the
russian federation grozny was level go
to grozny today the russians are
spending zillions on chechnya zillions
and this is peace building a lot of
russian people are very angry that their
government is so generous with
rehabilitating a former okay rebel
province are you saying i'm saying that
once you go to iraq you have to stay
specifically
once you go to libya that's very
important once you go to libya you have
to stay there you have to make sure that
the various militias are brought under
control that the government is is worth
more than its name that there is police
force that can protect at least their
prime minister that foreign embassies do
not get attacked that your own
ambassador is not killed that's what you
should be doing so the west has dropped
the ball uh it did yes
exactly like what dimitri says is this
the responsibility afterward you can't
as a western country also say just look
at it because the others should finish
their job by themselves that you can't
we cannot afford it also but the fact is
we have to take the responsibilities of
our actions and that after destruction
building takes such a long time and we
should have the breeze to do it and that
is what is missing in libya
we've got 30 seconds here
was germany
actually on the side of right when it
abstained from the resolution on libya
this was good and it was good that
the united states didn't make this
intervention in syria and what we should
do it would would be the role of germany
to be a fair negoti
mediator to help to find a solution and
i'm not on the side of the
of assad i'm not on the side of the
river i'm on the side of peace all right
we're gonna have to wrap it up there
peace is always a good way to wrap up
the show that's gonna end this edition
of agenda with brent goff remember you
can contact me anytime with your
thoughts on the show you can find me on
facebook you can tweet me at brentgoff
tv you can also send us an email you see
the address right there and if you want
to watch the show again go to our
website or watch us on youtube i'm brent
goff in berlin join me next time when i
set the agenda
you